but this is also like part of this deep
fakes like this deep fakes problem and
so if you don't know what a deep fake is
a deep fake is basically people can now
use technology to make a video look real
you can make anything look so for
example what they do is they'll take
Obama Obama's talking yeah but I can
just say any sentence I could just be
like hey hey my name's Barack and I'm
the worst president of all time and
it'll make it look like his lips are
moving to my sentence because they
basically feed in a bunch of footage of
Obama talking normally and it basically
the algorithm learns okay here's how
Obama's face moves when he says certain
things and then when I I can input any
audio and it'll make it look like he's
doing it now right now the technology is
where it looks a little off but it's not
that far off like if I showed it to my
god all they leave it off right but it's
just getting better month over month so
they just showed a like a paper just
came out with a new one and it's
literally just taking a still photo so
they took the Mona Lisa and then they do
the same thing I can go say a sentence
and it will make the Mona Lisa say it
like the voice can is that good so like
it's pretty crazy that they can just do
that off a still photo you don't even
need like hours and hours of raw footage
of the person in order to do this now so
I downloaded an app that does that with
the Mona Lisa which app is that do you
remember yeah it's amazing
I'll tell you what it's called it's
really neat and I think that everyone
should download this stuff I paid $5.00
for it it's called no I don't remember
the name of it I got no worries but what
do you think of this whole defacing cuz
there's a big problem like your sister's
a lawyer and I think she was she was
like a DA before right yeah well and
then she's a public defender in the
Bronx and people yeah now it's like if
you can't trust what you see right if
audio like we have photos that could be
Photoshop audio now that can be like
live bird I think
the name of it where basically you just
you just ha you can do you you can train
you can train this system to where you
could just type anything and it will say
it in your voice or it'll say Amen
Donald Trump's voice so if you can't
believe what you see what you hear or
what's in video then how does that like
mess up the world like fake news is
gonna become a bigger problem yeah it's
gonna become a problem why are we
defaulting to that why are we worrying
about I mean yeah it's gonna be a
problem but also let's think about all
the amazing things like like act like
there's gonna be fake actors like my
dance like your dance video like it's
gonna make movies amazing like like Brad
Pitt won't exist
don't be it will be it'll be a Jay Pitt
it will be something fake person and I
think that's awesome so here's a future
world you literally are just looking at
your computer and instead like today if
you want to make a movie or an animation
you have to like be an animator or a
movie editor or an artist to be able to
draw you're just gonna be able to say
things and it's gonna be able to create
what you're what you're saying so you're
gonna be able to say okay what if Donald
Trump was talking to you know whatever
Barack Obama and then Donald jumped in
the air and he said this and then
literally it's just gonna be able to
animate that's how that's how far this
is gonna go and that's gonna unlock the
ability to create stuff to people who
don't have the technical skills to do it
today yeah I mean I'm I'm not too
worried about how they're gonna regulate
it because like if you have a political
ad now it like anyone can run an ad on
Facebook or on TV and it says Donald
Trump I'm Donald Trump and I hate
Mexicans anyone can do that now but I
mean like literally the tech like you
could buy ads but there are ways to say
like well no that's not allowed and it
has to say like I'm Donald Trump and I
support this you know what I mean like
there are ways to like Woody man like if
you wrote a TV a political TV ad right
now it has to say who pays for it sure
it has to say is this like it doesn't
have to be it doesn't have to be a
political thing right this can go for
anyone someone in high school could just
bully somebody else like right
yeah I think things deep fakes got
famous because people were putting other
people's faces on porn actors and you
could make it look like I could take a
photo of your mom and I could put it on
it put it into a porno and it would look
like your mom's in the porno and people
were doing this with celebrities people
were doing this with their classmates
and you know the reddit the subreddit
for this got huge is all slob fix our
slash deep fakes and so this is how we
got popular because it was like this
incredible bullying tool like forget
about political ads it's just like
slander left and right it did it did it
get taken down that subreddit no I I
think it's still up I haven't been in a
long time but when it first blew up you
know it got really popular because
people were you know if oh yeah it is
banned from reddit now because it was
like it was becoming a problem oh yeah
but that didn't stop the actual the
actual problem it stopped the subreddit
where people are sharing it so so I
think there's going to be a massive
massive problem for evidence I think
it's a bit gonna become a massive
problem for just like slander and you
know spin like I could I could take a
video of you it'd make it say that you
hate Mexican people and it's not Trump
and and people would believe it because
they would see your face and they would
say I saw him say that yeah yeah I don't
know and so I'll tell you what some
people are trying to do to combat this
there's a whole bunch of programmers who
programmers in general I have a high bar
for the truth they really want things to
be true logical solvable rule up
reliable and so when you take away
evidence evidence which used to be a
source of truth it's like well you're
saying this but I have video of you
doing that thing so that's evidence but
now it's like well this video could be
anything this video could be fake so
they're trying to solve the way that
they think it can be solved so the
theory is anything you make to sort of
validate stuff the con artists will
always be one step ahead and there's too
big of a payoff to be able to fake this
stuff well it's like a counterfeit er
and so you're always a cat-and-mouse
game which is not a winning solution so
the solution that they believe is that
the phone makers themselves the device
makers themselves will need to put a
cryptographic seal on the video when
it's taken
it's like a tamper-proof seal like we
have with medicine or whatever where
it's like if this seal is broken that
means this videos been edited in some
way and so at some point people will
only trust videos or photos that have
this this cryptographic seal on them
that says this has not been edited
because it's it's on the device itself
from when it got captured it gets
instantly implemented on and so it was
working on that well the problem is
startup can't do this right because it's
actually Apple that needs to implement
it it's actually Samsung that needs to
implement this and so luckily apples are
pretty privacy conscious company and
they know that like if their tools are
being used for evil they'd usually
actually do stuff about it so hopefully
Apple is working on this but I have a
friend who was doing a start-up trying
to do this and he was running into this
problem which is like look the people
who need to do this are all all the
camera makers like you know the security
camera itself needs to do this and
that's the only like decent solution now
some technical people will say oh
there's nothing that's actually tamper
proof you can still you can still you
know get around it but it's better and
there they are right but there are still
things where it's mostly works right
exactly no I think that's the world
that's the way the world is going to
work later where you're gonna need to
see this little you know icon that says
it's like you know it's the gluten-free
icon it's the organic organic icon it's
gonna be this is legitimate and there's
gonna be a legitimacy icon on any foot
that's the icon business that's a good
business you know JD power
[Music]